thank you bology uh very popular we're
not YouTubers uh just to be clear um I
was here actually I was at the network
State last year and I expected it to be
the same as last year it was 20 people
at a
penthouse and I was very shocked to see
so many people coming today so bology
you've had some exponential growth it's
really exciting um okay so I came here
today uh to talk about media it's the
only thing I understand
and specifically I want to talk about
building
communities AKA countries on top of
social media in 2023 okay I came to this
conference because I'm really fascinated
with the idea of building your own
country and I really believe somebody
here in the audience at some point will
build their own country maybe it's you
maybe it's you maybe it's you okay
whatever it is it's it's going to happen
whether it's tomorrow or 10 years or 20
years from
now now my bet is that this new virtual
country will start as a Tik Tok account
it will start as a Twitter account it
will start as a YouTube
channel so I've been breathing and
living every single day social media for
the last s to eight years I understand a
thing or two about social media we built
a channel called Nas daily on top of
every social media that exists Instagram
Tik Tok Facebook YouTube Snapchat Doan
in China okay maybe V contact at some
point um and we've grown it to roughly
60 million followers in 13 different
languages it is possible it was possible
to build a business and a community and
a country on top of social media so it's
not possible today and I'm going to talk
about about why I'm going to talk about
the past of social media the present of
social media and the future of social
media the past of social media looked
something like this from 2015 to
2021 if you wanted followers if you
wanted a community just start a YouTube
channel start a Twitter account start a
Facebook Channel and you're
good this was fine and dandy all until
one problem came about what is that
problem does anybody
know saturation no it's not saturation
we're just
starting we are 1% of the creative
economy the problem is this Tick
Tock this new invention from China
changed the game of social media it
changed everything we know about
building an online community because Tik
Tok said I don't give a about your
community all I care about is showing a
nice video to my users and I want that
video to be short and if you dance it's
even
better so clearly now it doesn't matter
on Tik Tok if you have 500 followers or
5 million followers it doesn't matter if
the video is good you will get a lot of
views if the video is bad you're dead we
have 7 million followers on Tik Tok and
you can get 10 million views in video or
100,000 views you will never know and
this was so addictive that every social
media in the world copied it they were
like oh I'm going to become Tik Tok
YouTube copied it with YouTube Shorts
Facebook copied it with Facebook reals
Instagram copied with Instagram reals
now all social media roughly functions
the same this is the present of social
media where it's very very
algorithmically driven now can you build
a country on top of an
algorithm no you cannot imagine there's
a tornado and the president of a country
wants to inform the citizens of the
tornado and the algorithm says
nah I'm just not going to tell them
about the tornado it's like what like
these are my citizens you know so it is
impossible to build a business or a
community or a country for that matter
on top of social media that's why
Community one has a pro 1.0 has a
problem it has become a billboard it's
just TV the creator doesn't matter it's
just the video that matters and the only
one getting rich who's getting rich in
this
scenario the stock owner of the platform
that's it that's the only person getting
rich the employee and the investor of
Tik Tok and social media platform so
where is social media going from
here in my opinion the future of social
media looks something like this there
needs to be a layer two Solution on top
of social media just like we built it
for blockchain we need to build it for
social media and in this layer 2
solution there is no goddamn
algorithm there's no algorithm your
community your ownership you own the
data you own the audience you own it all
and actually we're starting to see a
little bit of that happening today
why do you think Discord is
Big why did Discord blow up during Co
you see it in the Discord chat groups
you see it in the telegram groups you
see it in WhatsApp you see it in slack
we're actually building our own platform
as well called Nas doio which is similar
to that idea it gives you a private
space where you control your community
and you are the one making the money
and I think in the future there's going
to be a huge explosion of these
platforms that sit on top of social
media there's also patreon there's also
substack by the way and when you design
social media from the beginning it has
to be Creator
first it should not be algorithm first
or user first the
founder is what matters because the
founder of the country is the one that's
going to make the country countries
don't have happen
organically and so in this
scenario the founder of the community
should be able to make money and own the
community can anybody guess how much
money do we make from a million views on
YouTube
5K 200 what 10 pound no not 10 pounds
okay 5K maybe in America but if it's
International it's 1K if it's in India
$200 if it's in other count so from $200
to 5K but the average is 1K how much
money do we make from 1 million views on
top of Tik
Tok pennies
zero it does not work the economics do
not work and that's why you should not
need a million people to make $1,000 you
should be able to make ,000 from a
hundred people that is the only way to
build a sustainable business a
sustainable community and So eventually
this is what I think will happen people
used to make $0 at the beginning of the
internet then roughly $10,000 if you're
a community Builder from Facebook
channels maybe some reddits maybe some
YouTubes actually most YouTubers are
broke do not be you know fascinated with
the top 1% most content creators today
are still broke eventually you'll start
to see the substacks and the patreons
and the nasos making $100,000 a month
from their community and eventually
somebody will make a million dollars a
month from an online community that's no
more than 10,000 people and when that
happens when that happens you'll have a
big business and when you build a big
business eventually that big business
will give more benefits to its members
it will give health care then it will
give real estate locations to meet at
travel together let's do things things
together and eventually it will give you
a passport and eventually it will
function like a state this is the
natural floww that I suspect will happen
for anybody that wants to build a
virtual online country in the future so
just to summarize in the last minute no
more slides just to summarize in the
last minute you're going to get
attention on social media here's my Tik
Tok here's my YouTube Here's my Facebook
then you're going to get get money on
another social media which is the
substacks the nasio the patreons and
whatnot you'll build that community and
then eventually that'll be a big
business and eventually it'll become
ideally a country maybe tomorrow maybe
10 years from now but I'm really excited
for that future thank you
guys
now before we go I just want to take one
video if we can turn the lights on
can you turn back the lights on I want
to take one video okay for social media
maybe we'll turn this into a video okay
I'm going to say welcome too and I want
everybody to say the network State okay
but I want your
energy so let's test can can you can you
light up the
audience so I'm going to say this okay
this is a test can you light up the
audience please so I'm say welcome
Tok the is this energy come on guys
the network State okay more energy okay
one two
3 welcome to network State okay let's do
one more time guys one more time the
network State not the network State the
network State okay let's start up the
audience
again and let's do yeah making content
is hard get you know how much money
we'll make from this
zero one two
three welcome to
[Applause]
[Music]
that was good that was good thank you
everybody